as many of you are start to plan your
summer vacations we are here to help how
we're beginning this hour with an
exclusive interview with Airbnb CEO his
name is Brian chesky he's a badass in
this business Airbnb says it expects
more than 300 million guest arrivals at
his properties this year 300 million 300
million say it again Nate that's right
500 million the company is making dozens
of changes to the platform to address
some of its users biggest concerns over
hidden fees security and prices Brian
chesky's Airbnb CEO and the co-founder
co-finder also pronounced co-founder hey
Brian it's really good to have you thank
you for having me Gail no we're glad
that you're here because this is the
thing
how many people how many CEOs say I want
the customers to speak I want to hear
your complaints and then they listen how
did what exactly did you do you
encourage people to complain yeah I mean
we looked through millions of customer
service calls I spend probably too much
time on social media looking at
thousands of social media posts we
talked to hundreds of thousands of guest
notes around the world and we asked them
what annoys you by Airbnb what can we
fix and I always wished CE more CEOs did
this and we went down all the feedback
we storyboarded the end-to-end
experience and we mapped the biggest
complaints based on severity frequency
and today what we have announced is over
50 improvements based on feedback
directly from the community basically
more transparent prices discount tools
for people to have better stays fewer
tasks when you leave your Airbnb faster
customer service ultimately we want
people to have amazing vacations
obviously and that means listening to
customers and improving based on what
they tell you why did you do that was it
painful to hear people could say to you
you know you could do this better Brian
Ryan Jessica was that painful for you
it's a little bit but like as long as
you remember that the feedback
ultimately is constructive the worst
thing is that people don't care the
worst thing is people don't care enough
to tell you because they want to use a
different service so the more they
complain I like to tell people that's
because they deeply are passionate about
travel they want to have great
experiences they like the brand and we
had to live up to that yeah all right
you also launched something called
Airbnb room yes tell me about that well
airmb actually started as a way to stay
in a room in someone's house I mean it
started one week and I couldn't afford
to pay rent my roommate all the hotels
are sold out we flooded these air beds
we call the air bed and breakfast well
15 years later we're going back to the
roots of the company because right now
as you know people are looking to save
money and so instead of booking a whole
home you can book a room in someone's
house the average price printed was only
67 a night it's a great way to have a
local experience and here's the key
thing you can virtually get to know the
people before you book okay you can read
their profiles you can see like there's
going to be a lock on the door you're
gonna have a private bathroom is there
gonna be a woman in the house is there a
man in the house you can decide it you
just you can pick who you stay with and
I think this is going to be great for
this travel you actually had people last
time you were here you told us you were
going to have people come stay yeah at a
room in your house yeah were you home I
was home so then November I announced
that I'm gonna put my bedroom on Airbnb
in my guest room yeah I've had three
sets of guests that one came from Brazil
one came from the Midwest one was more
local and we did this great experience I
stayed with me and my golden retriever I
made them cheskies chips these chocolate
cookies I make they've been in the
family recipe since I got off Google and
it's been really fun yeah but you've
been here twice and haven't bring bring
cookies
next time now you gotta bring me back on
all right um last time you were here you
also talked about how you guys were
navigating over the next few months and
yeah and how you were going to put your
foot on the pedal um you weren't going
to have any layoffs as we saw them
around the country with a lot of
corporate companies
um and then there were some layoffs um
kind of explained what happened were you
guys as profitable or not as profitable
as you thought and how we navigate them
oh we actually well we haven't had any
widespread layoffs the reality was um we
weren't hiring as many people so we
there was one Department recruiting
where we didn't need as many recruiters
because we've been pacing our hiring but
we have not had a widespread layoff
since 2020 when we did one we tried to
work with compassion and now we've been
really stepping on the gas I mean we are
expanding pretty aggressively a lot of
people want to travel and we want to
lean into that we're talking about being
volatile um is it difficult to run a
company like this
you know the great thing about Urban
bees is a pretty resilient model I think
what the pandemic it showed us is like
we lost 80 percent of our business in
eight weeks as you remember a lot of
people were predicting this is the end
of you thought your company was going
down and you know there's something
about staring the abyss you have a lot
of clarity and we realize is people
still love travel they still love
staying at home they still love Airbnb
and so we just like hunkered down and we
basically rebuilt the company from the
ground up and it's stronger than ever
what are you most looking forward to as
you sit here today
I'm just looking so the thing I think
I'm most looking forward to is what we
can do in the next year or two
ultimately I think Airbnb is about more
than staying in a home I think it's
about connecting people it's about
bringing people together through
cultures all over the world and I gotta
be honest I think the world probably
needs that more than ever now it seems
like the more time we spend online the
less time we're spending offline face to
face in the real world I think there's
this really a lot of more Rising
loneliness isolation in the world and I
think just if we can get more people
offline in the physical world coming
together that would be amazing and I
think that's what Airbnb is a great way
to bring together connection is key
chocolate chip cookies next time
yes thank you Brian what's your dog's
name uh Sophie Supernova okay Sophie